300 mil 101 decesos en mexico por kobe
19 es la cifra que alcanzó el viernes el
país latinoamericano se sitúa así como
el primero en número de muertes en la
región y el quinto en todo el mundo la
llegada de la variante o micro en menos
mortal pero más contagiosa dejó el
viernes imágenes de caos en el
aeropuerto de ciudad de méxico decenas
de vuelos fueron cancelados porque más
de 70 pilotos y 140 tripulantes de
cabina dieron positivo por kobe 19 si no
es terrible es terrible porque te venden
un tiquete te hacen venir al aeropuerto
literalmente te hacen hacer todo lo que
lo que tendrías que hacer sabiendo y
obviamente tendrían que haber salido que
su tripulación estaba en riesgo con
países como argentina uruguay o bolivia
registraron también el viernes sus picos
máximos de positivos por el virus brasil
sumó 63 mil nuevos contagios la cifra
más alta de los últimos seis meses allí
el alcalde de sao paulo anunció la
cancelación del carnaval en las calles
ante la situación sanitaria pero se
mantendrá el aforo limitado en el
sambódromo
en río de janeiro antiguas instalaciones
de los juegos olímpicos de 2016 se han
habilitado para la realización masiva de
test y 130 hombres maxim no tengo ningún
síntoma pero tuve contacto con mi hijo
que fue de viaje a buceo pero para
limpiar mi conciencia me hice la prueba
en el vecino colombia el viernes se
registró también el mayor número de
casos desde el pasado 6 de julio al
mismo tiempo el gobierno redujo la
cuarentena de 14 a 7 días me parece esa
medida buena siempre y cuando ellos se
incrementen la vacunación es decir
agilicen la vacunación para que el 100%
de la población colombiana de vacunar
entretanto cuba anunció la donación a
siria de 120 mil dosis de su vacuna
abdalá que alcanza una efectividad del
92 2% según las autoridades cubanas